there was this that was interesting
national police
defend response to the yeah why because
everyone's gonna say the nashville
bomber was white
yeah and they knocked on his door twice
and they gave up yeah yeah
listen everybody everybody in this car
here's why
i'm not saying the police aren't racist
but here's the problem with this
everybody in this country
is is is three to four days away from
detonating a bomb
somewhere that's every person if the
cops went to every that's every
commenter on my youtube
every person in america is three to four
days away
from just getting a [ __ ] gun and
going hog wild somewhere it's just
we're on the edge everybody's on the
brink so they can't waste their time
with every tip for every crazy dude
who's [ __ ] on the br i'm three to
four days away i'm doing okay i'm doing
well
and i'm three to four days away from
building a bomb and detonating outside
of
billy eilish's house so what are you
gonna do you're gonna check me out on
that i'll probably get up on that fourth
day and decide not to do it
because i've had a mcgriddle or
something i don't know but most people
are in lured fantasies of murder people
in this country are only kept alive
by two fantasies one getting really rich
and two
burning it all down those are the only
things people go to bed at night
thinking about murdering everyone they
know and
having a [ __ ] lamborghini those are
the two things in america
that unite us as a culture literally the
only two
that's the problem it's like they tried
to enforce that thing with kids
uh school shooters kids make lists of
people they're gonna kill and they're
like
we should but yeah but you should be
allowed you should be allowed to sit
there in the back of your marble
notebook
you know i'd really like to blow their
heads off
steve you know sharon paul
you're allowed until you do it until you
load the gun and go in there and do it
this preventative [ __ ] gets a little
creepy because most people are just
fantasizing all the time about killing
everyone that they know
that's absolutely true and if you're not
well god bless you but you're missing
out on the whole experience of america
the whole experience of america is
thinking about getting away with the
murder of your spouse
going nuts in your office and blowing
everyone's brains out
or finding a way to [ __ ] invest
successfully in a timeshare
that's it there's really nothing left to
do psychologically in this country
we are so drugged up on cheap food and
booze and pills
we can barely see straight we have no
idea what's going on we have no health
care
we have no insurance there's no
education people are [ __ ] stagnant
wages have stagnated
for [ __ ] decades and the you know
people have just jerked all the come out
of their dicks they're on too many
[ __ ] pills to even come they're just
coming air they can barely feel the
sensation of the tip of their penis
women have to shove [ __ ] hot pokers
in their vagina to get an orgasm
the only thing we have left is to
fantasize about the murder and
destruction
of our communities let us have it
you can't respond to everybody who talks
a little wildly at a bar about
settling scores because every day you
just
yeah did you say you were going to
show everyone at your office that you're
a real [ __ ] man
and you were going to end this once and
for all i quote
you're going to get respect one way or
the other i
quote and you're not going to be happy i
quote and when you see what i'll do to
you you won't be happy
you better run run i'll get like it's
just every day
so many fantasies of of murdering people
and you can't no obviously maybe they
should have done more
it clearly seems like it now
i mean hindsight is always 20 20 right
it's 20 20. but the fantasy life that we
all have
has been magnified by the internet it's
been magnified by our ability
to tell other people about these
fantasies and have them go that's a good
idea
and and it just because but that's why
you need comedy and that's why you need
freedom of speech that's why you need
all of these spaces for people to
release tension and say all this [ __ ]
and get it out
so that they don't do it because a
percentage of them are gonna do it
but it's important for people to let to
have these fantasies
you know what i mean it's important
probably porn even the porn has so many
negative effects it's important to have
a little porn so people don't you know
put their wife's head in the bag
so they go let me wat let me get off to
something
instead of making my wife do it i
shouldn't choke my wife till she turns
blue
but if i watch somebody get choked will
they turn blue maybe i get it out of my
system
that's porn it's a fantasy life it's not
real
sex doesn't feel like porn ever really
unless you're
amazing at it or in great shape sex is
different than the depiction of sex as
is murder i've never murdered anyone but
it looks amazing
watching the life leave someone's eyes
looks great
it looks amazing you and a buddy you and
your best bud go and just [ __ ]
murder someone you know just [ __ ]
blood everywhere and just [ __ ]
stabbing someone
but in real life that activity is
probably different it feels
different right but you should be able
to fantasize about it
you need you need these things so it's
hard to live in a free country where the
cops are always supposed to
respond to every [ __ ] utterance of a
person who's on a brink you know
how many people said they were gonna
spray paint nancy pelosi's
garage and leave a pig head on it many
probably many
but only one person did it and her name
is nancy pelosi
you see many people wanted to do that
but nancy pelosi finally did it
do you see how that works so that
somebody could be sympathetic and go
yeah
yeah they're stealing all our money and
they've destroyed the country
hollowed out many of our important
institutions
but you can't leave a pig head on the
[ __ ] dude
you left a pig head in the driveway it's
too much
i mean listen i get it i never advocate
violence i never advocate anything but i
understand why things happen
i don't have to advocate violence but i
understand what happens when you make
people desperate and scared they respond
like you ever corner an animal
you have a corner someone without
realizing you you're trying to get you
try to approach the dog the wrong way
and it bark and it bites you
this is what's happening with the
american public you're you're forcing
them into a corner and they're
scratching and clawing and they're gonna
come out and bite you i don't know did
that to pelosi's house
i have a good idea maybe i don't know
you know
it's probably oscar
would be funny if they arrested oscar
cat for that
san francisco he could have got up there
yeah absolutely could have he's a real
problem
or a solution